investigators searching for four missing
people in Pennsylvania have arrested a
man 20 year-old Cosmo DiNardo was taken
into custody yesterday on an unrelated
weapons charge
the FBI joined state and local law
enforcement officers to search his
family's property the four missing men
are 18 to 22 years old they were last
seen Wednesday through Friday of last
week DeMarco Morgan is here with new
details on the investigation DeMarco
good morning good morning norm right now
investigators are focusing the bulk of
their resources on searching a large
farm owned by the Denard O's the
district attorney says he is hopeful the
men are still alive but believes foul
play is involved and their disappearance
this investigation the leads are
incredibly hot they're very fruitful
we're making great progress law
enforcement is focused on this large
property in Solebury about 30 miles
north of Philadelphia it belongs to the
family of 20 gold Cosmo DiNardo the
young man was taken into custody
yesterday on an unrelated weapons charge
from February that the DA's office
refiled on Monday he is being held on a
million dollars bond
police also searched the DiNardo family
home in nearby Bensalem where Kozma
lives when asked what the interest was
in the DiNardo family the DA was vague
we have reason to believe that there
might be fruitful information that could
be gained from them while DiNardo is not
considered a suspect sources tell our
CBS station in Philadelphia that Cosmo
DiNardo is possibly connected to the
missing man all four men disappeared in
Bucks County 19 year-old Jimmy Tara
Patrick vanished on Wednesday 19 year
old Dean Finocchiaro was last seen
getting into a car early Friday evening
22 killed mark Sturgis and 21 yield Tom
Mayo were last seen together Friday
night and the Doylestown area it's
unclear if all four men know each other
or if any no DiNardo district attorney
Matthew Weintraub is confident the case
will be solved some investigations go on
until they Peter out and there's just
we're sort of grasping at straws we're
about as far from that as zero is to a
hundred Cosmo DiNardo was found in
possession of a 20 gauge shotgun when he
was
charged in February and by law he is not
allowed to have any weapons at all
because he was involuntarily committed
to a mental institution
authorities see a car belonging to one
of the missing men was found but they
found no evidence suggesting a crime
Gail all right thank you DeMarco